[Music]
the cubicle representative tyranny it
confines your imagination your thoughts
into a small physical area imagine
pretty much every software engineer or
finance person being able to you know
disconnect from their desk and look at
holographic monitors on a beach doing
their work from there that's not going
to be science fiction it's the modern
office place Silicon Valley is all about
building the future a startup called
meta thinks it's getting there first
thanks to a big bet that it's made on
augmented reality how are you thank you
call it a 360 degree office or you can
spatialize your thoughts as part of your
workflow for education architecture
design engineering etc people often mix
up augmented reality with virtual
reality VR totally blocks your ability
to see or hear the real world they are
overlays Holograms onto what you already
see meta has tried to make its version
of the workspace feels familiar
you grab the hologram instead of using a
controller or a mouse and your brain
already knows how to do it in other
words we've designed an operating system
that humanity has always known how to
use so you can see this eyeball which is
by the way photorealistic you can see my
hand is including the eyeball and now
the eyeballs including my hand right see
those two circles it gets small and then
they turn into the glowing white bond
and I can move my hand around
supernaturally I can do this with two
hands and rotate the thing I could
stretch it I could throw it back right
into the shelving system and that's all
you have to learn to become a modern
worker and to prove this the employees
at Mehta have started to get rid of
their computer monitors trading them in
for metas augmented reality headsets
we're own thinks that in less than a
decade we'll all be just wearing strips
of glass that can project Holograms in
[Music]
the early 80s everybody had computers on
their desktop but the one was using them
because they had a lot of work to do so
they were still using typewriters and at
some point the CEO took all the
typewriters away and everybody was
forced to use their computers so it's
very exciting to see a new generation of
technology a new paradigm I consider
it's like pioneers in the holograph of
wild I'm pulling up my browser with my
hand and sending out emails to colleague
and just kind of really relating to the
new environment
[Music]
now you're putting on my computer
essentially our digital lights live on
our phones we have all of our pictures
and notes and all the kinds of things so
why don't you write yourself a little
thinking out I like it and go ahead and
just take your fist right over the top
of the sticky note and close your fist
and now Medes own transition to
augmented reality has run into plenty of
unexpected problems and it's still going
to be a while before you start to see
these devices in your office but I think
it's a future worth waiting for if we
could see these Holograms between us we
will have been able to share our work
with one another more naturally more
efficiently and more productively than
ever before humanity will have evolved
slightly
you